[Musique]
mam usagers les objets ne se jette pas
les exos l'ont bien compris ils
démontrent que la musique ce n'est pas
si compliqué c'est une vue de l'esprit
est un petit peu une image mais il
n'empêche que ça va ça montre que on
peut faire des choses avec des objets
qu'habituellement on balance on en
distribue un petit document qui
récapitule un petit peu ce qu'on a fait
qui donne les dimensions exactes des
tuyaux et le truc c'est là vous pouvez
rentrer chez vous pouvez démonter toutes
les tuyauteries inutile le musée de la
ville ouvrait plus longuement ses portes
à l'occasion de la nuit des musées une
soirée sous le signe des objets du
quotidien
465 personnes ont répondu présentes
le public de la nuit des musées c'est un
public un petit peu différent c'est sur
une proposition en soirée donc plus
convivial où musée est un petit peu vu
différemment que on a tous voient
toujours de manière un peu austère quand
il est ouvert la journée là c'est
l'occasion aussi de montrer que c'est un
lieu ouvert à tous un succès confirmé
dans d'autres sites yvelinois au palais
du roi de rome de rambouillet près de
200 visiteurs ont enquêté sur les
mystères du site